[Music]
serena williams is opening up about her
love story and the only reason she'd
give up tennis for good Serena's big
confession if I weren't working I'd
already be pregnant I don't know if I
want to play if I have another baby the
36 year old mama also reveals how nine
month old Olympia changed her life
adding since she was born
I haven't been apart from her for more
than a day so more babies could be in
the future for the 39 time Grand Slam
winner who admits being a mom and a
world-class athlete can be challenging
I'm in the locker room pumping before a
match because my boobs are so big when I
pump they go down a size or two and I go
out and play but that's exactly why
Serena's gracing the cover of in style
magazines first-ever badass women issue
the tennis pro serves up some intimate
details like how she knew hubby internet
entrepreneur Alexis Ohanian was the one
it was his tech savvy conversation I had
this sense like I'm going to marry this
guy I love his world as for who she
thinks is a fierce female Serena's list
includes Beyonce Rihanna and Kate
Middleton she even dishes on being there
for her pal Meghan Marcos Royal Wedding
it was super fun and what she worries
about most of course it's Olympia's
well-being
[Music]